i want to make sure that i i talk about
promising young woman
because yes please uh uh this movie
there's and it's a cliche to say there's
a lot of buzz about this movie
there truly is uh so much chatter
about this film and um
i think it's a very hard film to
categorize it's mesmerizing it's
fantastic
all the performances are great uh
and it feels like a very important movie
and
at the same time there are moments that
i thought were
very funny and then of course there are
moments that are really harrowing and
heartbreaking
and it's just beautifully done it's
really beautifully done
yeah emerald fennel who wrote and
directed it
um she is
unbelievable um she had written the
script and i remember reading the script
and being like i don't know
i'm not even sure what the tone is of
this movie um
and i thought and and then she they'd
cast a bunch of people like
christopher minsplatz and and adam brody
and all these sort of comedic actors and
i thought
what is like i really didn't understand
what because it didn't totally read
right um and then i had a conversation
with her
and i was so blown away and she was so
focused and had such a
clear vision of what this thing was
supposed to be and really executed
everything on every level and i remember
seeing the movie and going
oh my oh my goodness and the reason we
can't we could show a clip
of me in the movie it's a spoiler which
i swear i'm in
yeah is a spoiler and
yeah it it it really um
and i i just can't say enough about her
and yeah and
the same goes for carrie mulligan who's
amazing
carrie milligan's great but i also think
there was a decision
and when people see the movie they'll
understand but
uh you know bo burnham's in it all these
and and
and you are cast in it and what what
happens is you get
so many very funny likable
[Music]
guys that we already know and like and
think are funny
and then they're put in this context
that uh
almost takes advantage of the fact that
we're familiar with you
and we like you and turns its turn is it
on it on its head which i thought was
very powerful yeah you know there's
there's been an interesting reaction
some people totally get it and then
there are other people who watch the
movie specifically with
with uh you know the scenes that i'm in
and think i don't understand why you
would
put somebody like max from the movie
yeah because
uh the scene is so dramatic why would
you take a a
comedic actor and put him in there it
somehow makes
the scene almost come across comedic
well i was blown away by this movie
people should watch it promising young
woman is now in theaters
and available uh at home on demand
and people should watch it i think
people will watch it because the word of
mouth is
insane plus new episodes of the
neighborhood air
mondays on cbs are you guys able to be
shooting that now
or is it is it still impossible yeah
we're yeah we're back up we
we've been really fortunate we'd be able
to do the show and um
we're we've shot quite a few episodes at
this point that's great
it's really exciting so hopefully we can
finish that out
and it's been wonderful